[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
that's what i'm talking about
that's what i'm talking about
no check this out
[Music]
this
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about
go check this
out three
drop the bench
[Music]
so
hello and welcome to that
wait what episode number are we on again
the fourth
so let's count we started with
introducing aden caldwell the
protagonist that's true and then we
looked at some of the monsters we'll
find in the city
exactly and then it was parkour and
creative combat wow all right well four
episodes already thank you so much for
joining us on this journey and if you
missed any episodes so far they're all
on our youtube channel for you to catch
up and we have already shown you so much
it might seem you know everything about
the game but
but it's just the tip of the iceberg so
let's dive a bit deeper today we're
going to show you the vast open world of
dying light 2. even though it's violent
brutal and full of death you'll find
there's a surprising amount of beauty
and vibrancy in the city and you will
hear a lot about exploration freedom
interaction and some secrets you may
find in the city and at the end of this
episode there's going to be one secret
less because we're going to be doing a
big old hollywood name drop and showing
you a new big name in the world of dying
light 2 stay human who is it
we have to wait till the end to find
out there are many elements that create
the open world of dying lights to stay
human the city has a diverse
architecture with historic churches a
business district modern apartment
blocks and old villador
it is full of immersive sounds that fill
the streets and there are plenty of
characters that you will meet along the
way but it's impossible to talk about
all of this at once so let's start with
the places that you will visit and
explore during your journey and for that
i have my next guests katarinanska
senior concept artist and by thor
janoskevich lead 3d artist
[Music]
as we know villadore is unlike any city
we have seen before mostly because the
pandemic and the apocalypse have left
their marks on the city but what exactly
are those marks yes we wanted the player
to feel the past of the city want while
they're exploring it
see the city's old glory
this old civilization it's old monuments
of his old heroes big skyscrapers tv
tower or all abandoned
subway stations or even an abandoned
cargo ship i mean the city's hades are
clearly behind us but if you explore it
fully you find old traces of the city
just before the spread of the haram
virus that's very true
also during exploration the player will
see that citizens of the city are trying
to bring back some of the aspects of
let's say formality
and yes they are fully aware that it's
pointless but they are still trying to
give you an example we'll meet a manhood
to add some love to the city created
something that's similar to today's
dating gaps we'll also have a chance to
listen to an opera singer who sings
areas from years ago among the ruins and
those are the colorful characters i
mentioned anything to add yes it's
definitely worth exploring the major
bass city of our game besides the
player's main goal side quests and
missions you can venture back to the
past of the city once called villador
you can find old traces of newspapers
recordings of the mayor's speeches books
posters and many many other objects that
will give you that feeling and history
about that whole city this also the past
can come back in the form of audio
cassettes especially the ones recorded
by a father who's desperately seeking to
find out what is happening with his
daughter oh i know this story very well
and it is quite emotional right yes
indeed okay bartek thank you kasia to
you as well thank you for joining me
of course we have just scratched the
surface of what's there in the game but
we will let you to discover it by
yourself
speaking of exploration you can't jump
into the city just yet but you can start
by exploring the very place where
everything began haran from dying light
one and much more as the platinum
edition of dying light is coming this
year to nintendo switch on october the
19th and yes you can already pre-order
it you can find more details on our
website switch.dyinglike
so check it out after the episode
all right back to villadore we've
glimpsed it's past we've seen it's
present what about the future of the
city here to talk to us about that today
is thomas chabot the world director of
dying light ii
[Music]
hello it's good to see you again so can
we do more than simply explore the city
yeah much more you see when you first
arrive in the city you discover a
decaying metropolis whose best glory you
can really just imagine and if you ask
me there's already beauty in that but
you know what's even more beautiful than
a dying city seen it come back to life
exactly in the first moments of the game
when aidan makes it through the wall the
infrastructures are decaying falling
apart or destroyed but some are just
dormant waiting to be revived so for
example we have several electrical
stations throughout the city and of
course these have been offline for ages
but if you choose to do so you can
attempt to fix them
and if you succeed it's a real game
changer
[Music]
with electricity back on the face of the
city changes storefronts ladder events
turn on and help with the navigation
electrical traps become available to
fight the infected and all world
remnants just come back to life and you
can explore these if you don't learn
about the history of the space oh and i
do want to learn about the history so we
can revive the city literally then yeah
but there are many more ways in which
the choices of the player will shape the
world around them okay and what kind of
choices are we looking at well actually
as you restore power to the city and
help a new civilization rise on top of
the old one you're given one central
choice
which faction are you gonna side with
it's called the city alignment system
and besides gameplay consequences it
will give you the power to shape the
skyline of the city literally you see
peacekeepers or survivors according to
your choice will build different
structures with a different function
outbound different characters inside of
them okay um that's quite vague can we
have a specific example in-game of what
that might look like yeah for sure let's
look at this situation so in this case
for example we chose to help the
survivors what we're going to see is
they are going to build a school on the
rooftop and inside of it is a teacher
teaching the kids
now let's look at what would happen if i
chose the peacekeepers instead you see
the school is turning into a pk rooftop
outpost and inside of it is now a
shopkeeper with whom i can actually
trade and outside is the npc who may
just have a specific quest for me
oh so we've gone from a teacher to a
shopkeeper here i mean can we actually
interact with these npcs yeah absolutely
actually let's look at it this way if
you were to go to a foreign place you
would probably want to talk to the
locals to learn about where to go where
to sleep where to eat where to party
maybe it's the same in our city you can
talk to the locals to learn about the
insider secret of the city and actually
answer some important world questions
you know just learn to get around in our
city oh yeah absolutely but what about
when the sun says
well then it's a different thing you
know you will learn about urban legends
folktales and actually ranging from
campfire stories through songs to
rooftop theater people will always need
stories to learn how to live and it's
especially important in our city and who
knows if you pay attention maybe you'll
realize that some of your actions some
of the choices you make in-game become
stories told on the rooftops so i could
be an urban legend in the game that's so
cool i mean it sounds like i'm going to
need multiple playthroughs to really
fully experience the richness of these
choices in these worlds well thank you
so much for joining us today thomas it's
been a pleasure thank you leah
if you'd like to start exploring the
world of dying light to stay human
already why don't you go to
techlandgg.com where you'll find our
whole new section with stories about the
citizens of vilador check them out now
and let us know on our social media what
you want to hear about
and while you're there don't forget to
grab other rewards and goodies such as
these new weapons the dragon breath bow
and the neon storm ye old trusty go to
techlandjuji.com to get them now
my next guest is the composer of the
dying light 2 stay human soundtrack
olivier de riviere
[Music]
i want to talk about what the main
inspiration for the soundtrack was then
the main inspiration came from the
creative director who gave me one word
broken
so that was very inspiring because it's
a strong word and we wanted to spread
that idea through the city the main
characters the story everywhere not only
through the story actually but also
through the gameplay so every actions
everything you're doing is supported by
music okay that's a pretty strong main
theme and does that change depending on
who we're talking to or what we're doing
yeah definitely what we wanted to do is
to have something that will be impactful
for players that would be recognized so
for instance you have factions in this
game those factions have a musical theme
and then as you are giving away some
zones giving away some buildings
location you will give that to a certain
faction therefore you will have a
certain music attached with the faction
and therefore the music will sound
depending on your choices which is like
creating the soundscape of the city out
of your choices wow yeah so you're
making a quite personal experience then
as you make your own little mini
soundtrack definitely it's really cool
so it sounds quite interactive it is
very interactive
let's take like um that i mean
throughout all the gameplay mechanics we
have there is parkour of course and the
idea is like on the ground level there
is like death there is nothing
and so we didn't want to have music
there but on the rooftop where life is
back we wanted to have a sense of
freedom so parkour happens there and you
have the music at first if you just run
what happens is like the music is just a
soundscape something that's you know
it's not big but the more moves you do
the more crazy stuff you're doing jump
over the you know the building the walls
and everything the bigger the music to
such an extent that's at some point the
music kicks in into a flow parkour flow
and now you don't even want to stop
parkouring because the music is pushing
you to do that yeah yeah that sounds
really like rewarding it is very
rewarding making your own little awesome
soundtrack as you go um what about the
combat then is that the same yeah the
combat has the same treatment of being
interactive so you would have to meet
you know any enemy with a special melody
special theme but mostly it's about your
actions so if you go and fight and
decide to very to be very very blunt the
music will react to this as well as you
know if you kill somebody if you get
away like running away from the enemy
and everything is supported by the music
okay all right i mean that sounds really
intense there's a lot going on it sounds
like the kind of thing we need to be
able to see and hear together to truly
appreciate so why not take a look
[Music]
yes
[Music]
wow i mean yeah you can truly appreciate
how it's all coming together and making
again a really personal feeling
experience um but does that kind of
change depending on where we are in the
map like what location we're in right it
definitely changes depending where you
are in the game so
when you start the game the music would
be sort of like soundscape moody some
little things you know we don't want to
to be too
too too big but as the player goes and
as you understand more of the story as
you getting more empowered the music
grows and grows and grows to such an
extent that's at some point the music
get a new treatment and an orchestra is
now supporting your actions and the
story yes so now it's the next level for
the music
but you know however what we wanted to
support as well is the personal story of
aiden and for that we wanted to have a
very special sound very special
instrument that will make the sort of
like emotional
okay well i mean i really really want to
know more about this but i am going to
have to stop it there unfortunately
because we need some secrets for next
time of course um well thank you so much
for joining us olivier it's been a
pleasure and i can't wait to hear the
soundtrack thank you
none of the things that we are talking
about here today would be possible
without the work of sound level
designers such as edita machines
kaduraska who makes it all work in the
game
[Music]
hello editor hi we are kind of mediators
i think between the composer olivia and
the game we implemented his music and
vision into dying light 2 making sure
that it all works as it's supposed to
like for example uh since we have so
many teams
the soundtrack must switch to another
system whenever player wanders off the
main plot
whenever the whether they fight walls
search for mia parker or enter dark zone
we see to it that the music gets all the
changes and details in exactly those
moments olivia imagined and we know that
music changes when you parkour fight or
enter locations right yeah sure but how
exactly does it work so every system
works
a little bit different
but in fact it all comes down to
creating special zones scripting and
level design and we had to set up all of
this manually for example
the music needs to know if the player is
sparkling in a dangerous or safe place
if they are jumping over the street
uh what kind of enemy they are fighting
what's the enemy's faction and dragons
so on and so on so on and the music
knows it's all mostly thanks to special
invisible zones that we add inside the
game okay invisible zones this sounds
intriguing so what are they and how many
of them are there in the game oh there's
so many of them i guess millions
probably
they are let's say
boxes triggering when the player enters
them whenever that happens they tell the
music that it needs to change but
you know that's the easy part
the hard one is to set up them properly
and fit them into geometry of the world
so they send right a message at the
right moment i think that the windmill
was really challenging in that muscle
and why was it so so as as the player
climbs the windmill the music changes
depending on the height but let me
assure you that players will
hear
the amazing music and sounds that you
have put into the game thank you editor
thank you
if you thought the dying lights who
soundtrack couldn't get any more
impressive then we have something else
to show you it was played by none other
than the london contemporary orchestra
in the world famous abbey road studios
check this out
[Music]
generally i try to get the
the core the substance of uh let's say a
word through an instrument
and this time i had to go back to my
friend nicole
who's
making instruments out of junks
literally junks
and he created this instrument that
could be in the world of dialect to
completely like
accurate with all the little details and
sort of you know the roughness of the
instrument
[Music]
[Music]
now it's time for something special we
already know aidan the protagonist of
dying light to stay human and hakon who
in our game has the face of david bell
the inventor of parkour david bell now
let's meet another important citizen
yeah and that's the perfect time to show
you the surprise we have saved for last
you may know her from the mandalorian
series or from the famous sin city so
without further ado meet lawn
hi i'm rosario dawson though in dying
light 2 you will know me as laun a
warrior of sorts a very tough woman who
is fighting her past
and looking to seek revenge on the
people who wronged her now what i really
love about this game and this character
is that
how she is
is really dependent on you the player
is she going to be this rage-filled
killer who is obsessed with her goals
or
will she be a night runner who risks her
life to save others
it's up to you
senior writer piot mostowski will tell
us more about lawan hello
[Music]
so let's talk about lawan lawan is
one of the strong self-reliant women in
the world of dying light to stay human
she is an important character with a lot
of impact on the plot
but we also wanted her to be
way more than that to be
a real person with her own goals her own
motivations and her own opinions as well
so if she doesn't like something you do
or something you say she will tell you
that and
and she will act on it
you know sometimes
even against you and you will feel the
consequences of it she is her own boss
and her kill list is open so you don't
want to end up on it she has a kill list
no
no i need to know more about that
guys let's stop here because that's a
spoiler peter
tell us more why did we chose rosario to
become lavon
because lawan is uncompromising and
she's tough and you are going to have a
lot of crazy adventures with her
sometimes balancing on the verge of life
and death you know and in the process
she can become your dearest friend or
your enemy at some point so in order to
convey all that because there is quite a
lot to convey
we needed an extraordinary actor and
rosario turned out to be just perfect
you know and i cannot wait to meet her
in game thank you so much for joining us
today thank you thanks thanks
dying light to stay human is just a few
months away and on february the 4th
we'll finally be able to experience its
vast and vibrant open world complex
characters and gripping stories
thank you for joining us today next time
we'll show you what choices you might
encounter in the city and the ways in
which you can change the world
stay safe stay human
[Music]
you